a vasectomy is a permanent method
of birth control for
men in which the surgeon cuts
and ties off part of
the male reproductive tract to
prevent sperm from leaving
the man's body during ejaculation the male's
reproductive system  man
includes the testicles two
oval structures where sperm
are produced the male reproductive cells each
testicle connects to the
vas deferens tubes that carry sperm to the
urethra a canal in the penis that
carries urine and sperm
during ejaculation each duct  vas
propels sperm through the
seminal vesicles and
prostate gland structures that provide
nutritive fluid and transport for
sperm now called semen this
combination of sperm and
fluid substances continues its journey through
the urethra and is expelled through the penis
during intercourse  sexual the semen
passes the reproductive system fe
where sperm can find and
fertilize an egg if you don't want
to get a woman pregnant you can choose a
birth control method from one
of several categories abstinence
to completely avoid pregnancy by
not having sex
contraception to temporarily avoid
pregnancy  through the use of various
methods during sexual intercourse
or sterilization to
permanently prevent pregnancy through
a medical procedure vasectomy is
a form of sterilization before
starting the procedure you will be
given injections of
local anesthetic to numb the area in a
conventional vasectomy uses a
scalpel to make a
small incision on one side of your scrotum the
thin skin sac that houses the
testicles
your doctor will locate the
vas deferens and lift it through the
incision at this time you may
have a feeling of tightness
the vas deferens will be cut and s  e
a small part will be removed then the
recently cut ends of the vas deferens will be tied off will be ligated with
surgical clips or characterized the
vas deferens will be placed
back into the scrotum and sutured a
the same steps will be repeated on the other
side of the scrotum this procedure
takes  about 30 minutes
in the no-scalpel method your doctor
will use a special ring clamp to
grasp and expose the
vas deferens from this point
onwards the procedure is the same
as for conventional vasectomy
this method  is usually associated
with faster healing and fewer
complications and is as effective as the
conventional method
immediately after any of
the procedures you will be asked to
rest in the doctor's office
for a short time the incisions will
heal within a few days leaving a
small or  no scar after the
procedure will need to be cleaned  Limit
your physical activity for one or two days You will
not be able to shower for 24 hours You will
need to avoid lifting
heavy objects Doing heavy work or
exercising too much for five to seven
days You will need to avoid
sexual activity for 7 days